[Music]
good job kuduri board start with your
anchor items like samosas and add your
favorite chutneys and dips hit up with
toppings like potatoes and chickpeas
layer in your chopped crispies fill in
these spaces with your favorite sweets
either blood doesn't parliy g garnish
with jalapenos and billboard and enjoy
your jack kuderi board how to make mint
chai add water to your cup this is 16
ounces and i'm making two cups turn the
heat on medium and add water to your
tripod take one half inch of ginger and
crush this really brings out the flavor
of the ginger add one half teaspoon of
fennel seeds two cardamom and two cloves
crush well and add to your boiling water
add two tablespoons of tea powder let
the tea and spices mix together for
about one to two minutes next add your
milk this is one cup of whole milk you
can use any milk that you like let the
milk boil and turn the heat down take
your mint muddle a bit and add to the
chai the mint really marries the spices
and tea together
i don't add sugar but if you like sugar
add it now strain your chai i love this
pretty tea strainer and these glass mugs
add your favorite chai biscuits sweets
and enjoy your mint jar if you grew up
eating egg puffs you gotta try this easy
five ingredient recipe for the base use
pasta sauce is a quick and easy hack hit
it with chopped masala garam masala and
chopped coriander i'm using quant puff
pastry sheets add the base and a quarter
hard-boiled egg add water to the edges
to seal and a fork to close coat the
little egg wash and bake baked golden
brown and enjoy your easy five
ingredient egg puffs growing up i didn't
like bringing daisy food on their family
trips now that i'm an adult i bring our
daisy food on all our trips here's how i
make a daisy family picnic pork start
with that foil packet or protectla add
your snacks like masala chips good date
biscuits and packets of crackers add
your favorite maggie garnish with parley
g and enjoy a daisy family picnic board
jc pasta chips i tried the trending
pasta chips but it kicked up the heat
with a bakey twist boil your pasta and
add olive oil add hot and sweet maggie
sauce and your spices like chocolate
salad red chili powder and enter powder
give it a mix and bake in the oven or
air fry they come out so spicy and
crispy give it a try or make your own
intact if you like the chocolate report
then let me put you on to corn chop
kudery cups cut your tortilla into four
quarters place the tortilla into the
bottom of a cupcake pan bake at 350 for
10 minutes roast your corn to give it a
crunch add in chopped onions tomatoes
and cilantro through the chocolate red
chili powder salt and fresh lime juice
give it a mix scoop into your tortilla
cups garnish with seed and enjoy your
chat kudu cups
[Music]
ah
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
you